jared kushner donald trump's son-in-law
husband of ivanka
appeared on fox news he was asked about
these documents that donald trump stole
and kept in his house and jared kushner
played about as dumb as i've seen
anybody play this this really takes some
skill to play this dumb
leading political opponent is very
serious it's a very serious thing i
think that americans on both sides of
the political aisle have some real
questions about what they did um there's
a section in the book where you talk
about the zelinski transcript and you
argued let's get it out there let's just
put it out there so are you arguing
right now to your former boss and
father-in-law you know put out what
these documents are put out what they're
about in these in these presidential
documents tell everybody what's in there
yeah well i i don't know whether he
knows what's in the boxes or not again
these were boxes that were in storage if
you know anyone knows donald trump knows
he keeps a ton of stuff they're always
in boxes all over the place and you know
who knows if there were things that he
did intentionally unintentionally yeah
he not only might he not know what was
there
those things maybe were unintentionally
there now here comes the it's already
getting it's stretching credulity but
then it gets really weird there's
reports i've read that the gsa packed
the boxes so like i said i think that
right now what we want to know is what's
in the affidavit i think that's the
transparency we should get to but i do
think president trump was probably one
of the most transparent presidents that
we've had in a very long time now of
course that's completely untrue missing
call logs from january 6th all sorts of
obfuscation people missing from white
house visitor logs arguably again
democrats are going to do voter fraud
what they meant was we're going to try
to steal an election trump was the most
transparent really trump was the least
transparent and he sat for interviews
all the time he was always asking
answering questions from the press you
knew what he thought of at 12 o'clock at
night when he would tweet you know what
he thought at six in the morning when he
would tweet yeah and so i know he
definitely is is often on the side of
transparency have you asked him you know
if he knows what's in there or if he
went through them or if he intentionally
kept something back when the fbi when
the lawyer said that they had already
taken out everything that was classified
i haven't asked him that but i i have
been with him since then and he hasn't
seemed too concerned about it
[Laughter]
right uh
one of the
as they love to say
an unprecedented situation in
presidential history where a search
warrant is served the president's home
because of the documents he stole
jared acknowledges he's hung out with uh
trump since
but they just haven't talked about this
it just didn't come up if you can
believe that okay um you know and martha
mccallum okay okay i'm just accepting it
martha mccallum should be ashamed
jared kushner should be ashamed but
again
this is happening on a network fox news
where they just believe stuff they
believe what they're told they don't sit
and think you know these aren't really
tough questions and there's no
follow-ups and jared's explanation makes
no sense no they just go let's listen
they just they've met but jerry doesn't
know he hasn't talked to trump about it
as his one of his closest advisors from
the entire presidency
it simply didn't come up they were
talking about golf and well done steak
and putting ketchup on steak that was
really the only thing they talked about
but on fox news the what the viewers
just accept it they go yep that's what
it was they talked about other things
i'm really excited that one of our
sponsors today is helix sleep i sleep on
a helix mattress at home i absolutely
love it and that's why i reached out to
them about sponsoring the david pakman
show
buying a mattress in the past
was always a huge guessing game for me i
didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like but helix
has a sleep quiz on their website you
tell them your body type your sleeping
position your back pain issues you might
have and their tool matched me with a
mattress that is perfect for me it's
cool enough at night it's the right
firmness i generally just do way better
sleeping these days because of the
mattress helix was awarded number one
best overall mattress for the last two
years by both gq and wired magazine it
is well deserved i can tell you
firsthand every helix mattress comes
with a 10 year warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights and they will even come pick
it up at your house if you don't love it
but i know you will for a limited time
helix is offering up to 350 off all
mattress orders plus two free pillows at
helixsleep.com
pacman it's the biggest discount they've
ever offered the link is down below